they thought we were offering help they
thought we were bringing aid to a
community in Barrow called mango mass
Karina but the celebratory shouts soon
turned to anger and despair
[Applause]
[Music]
mm people have been waiting at this
primary school for a meal
or a cup of porridge they can take home
to their families and they've been
waiting for days they took our phone
numbers and our names three days ago
they said they were bringing supplies
but they haven't done anything
soldier it's a cyclone edye has leveled
homes and businesses and disrupted the
power and it's also knocked out the
government mr. Pamela who is the
Secretary of the local municipality has
put what little food he does have under
armed guard until now we've had nothing
from government okay they gave us 500
kilograms of porridge but for 2,000
people it's not enough increasingly
agitated the crowd demanded he released
the grain but mr. Pamela told them his
supplies were rotten a few hundred
meters away we witnessed a similar scene
of desperation men with a tank of clean
water were trying to make a delivery and
word soon got out within minutes
neighbors were fighting their neighbors
the truck drove off without dispensing
its load as the crew tried to ward off
the needy the authorities and the aid
agencies have had a week to assess the
scale of this disaster but it's been a
struggle 15,000 people are still
stranded by the floodwaters and a
shortage of rescue teams and helicopters
like this outfit from South Africa makes
the situation worse nonetheless hundreds
of lives have been saved in the last few
days in mango masks arena the survivors
of this storm will have to start again
and faith may be the only thing that
fuels them for there's little food and
no clean water John sparks Sky News in
bearer